it is officially time the stanley cup
finals colorado versus tampa here in
denver we are at ball arena let's go on
inside and see what is going down my
first ever stanley cup finals appears
and it is looking beautiful here
morningscape finishing up the abs had
the first one tampa's getting ready to
come out
this is gonna be sick we are here
outside the arena it is about an hour
until game time it is absolutely
electric the fans are starting to funnel
in the drums going on in the background
we got the twig we got a nice little set
up here there's a guy playing goalie
let's rip him
tall philosophy aspen that's darcy
kemper in that right there just getting
warm right now
this is the beginning of playoffs it's
in lucky crystal it's magic i just
appreciate you blessed to the hockey
gods
and the colorado avalanche made the
avalanche come in huge plus yes
i've never felt this much energy in the
arena before game it's been a long time
since they've had the opportunity game
one
stanley cup
absolutely buzzing him
all right we got it to the as merch
store i've been seeing people rocking
the we want the cup chains i think we
have to get one
ripped out we got the chain we got the
shirt time to get to our seats this is
sick period number one absolute madness
three one craziest building that i've
ever seen you're the man what's up man
what's going on the fans here are
showing so much love this building is so
loud see what they thought about it i
mean it is just crushing the abs are
buzzing the boys are buzzing let's go
we're going to win this thing who's
getting the next goal here i think i'm
going to go palace yeah call the player
right up the point's going to get in
there okay who's scoring the next goal i
would say go in the car baby okay
i'm rocking the tapes
thank you
i mean what better way to spend the
intermission than with this nice churro
we've been smelling it in the arena
everyone's hyping these up it's time to
give it a go you know what
it lives up to the hype maybe it's just
because it's a stanley cup churro but
i'm going a nice eight out of ten on the
trio get in the second period here's
palat
with kucher off trailing right in the
slot dangles around and they score
palat tips it in our abs that was tough
kutra with the nasty dangle shout out to
the guy who called palat scoring the
first goal back paula because he did
score off that coutron move kind of
feeling a little ot here i don't know i
need to experience some ot stanley cup
finals hockey do it conference is shot
blocked by hedman score
burakovsky
on the follow
and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's absolutely the craziest thing that
i have ever seen the ot banger wide open
one team and this city has just erupted
fans are absolutely loving it you cannot
ask for a better finish than what we had
right there
here we are after the craziness of last
night it's a beautiful morning here in
denver now we're here for some business
to watch some hockey but we're here for
some fun too now as you know there's
lots of teams in the nhl right now
they're out golfing but there's two
there are not aqua golf denver the
beautiful open range instead of shooting
on the grass it's just the wide open
water
[Music]
are you kidding me
it skips in
bag three okay we can't be too loud at
the golf course you know it's not it's
not ball arena right now this place is
unreal there's no games going on here
but we're still getting some hockey
going in the city of denver we're
traveling around the city getting moving
we got our green biscuit we got our
skates let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the elevation hits different the views
also hit different next stop tampa we're
headed to the watch party there in tampa
for game two the actual game three and
of course we'll be taking you guys the
entire way
we just landed in tampa this is what
it's like traveling with the hockey gear
the camera gear shout out to the pilot
at the end of his little speech a rival
speech he's like go avalanche the booze
erupted the fans are into it you can
tell it's gonna be electric here it's
watch party time we still got an hour
and a half until game time it gets close
to a sellout crowd for a watch party
which is wild all right we got the two
rings i just want to say i've seen so
many lightning fans come up they've been
throwing up the threes down one up maybe
a little bit too early you're looking
kind of fire i mean how about a fire
truck to go along with it are you
kidding fully kitted out custom made we
thought the ash fans went crazy but this
is an away game and equally as much
craziness time to enter the arena get to
our seats we're just gonna be sitting in
the stands getting you guys the
authentic experience let's head on in
there
you guys know the drill first stop it's
always the merch store yes we already
have the tampa one but we had to check
out the new stuff beautiful tie-dye
that's just the florida vod you know i'm
picking up one of these we'll maybe get
another chain again i got to be unbiased
right we bought the colorado chain now
we got to rep the tampa chain new chain
new day this is the tampa fit we need
you guys to let us know in the comments
below tampa fit
colorado fit
i have no idea what this is oh
we're lighting up okay okay
all right game just started up here
i mean this place is packed and i also
just witnessed nine different hype
videos the production value
lightning's coming down from the ceiling
this place is crazy all right so we
gotta wait and see when the first goal
comes see if this place er up let's wait
it out
[Music]
that's a quick two for colorado
probably the worst period of hockey that
i've ever seen from the tampa bay
lightning listen we did the churros in
denver we got the pretzel sticks here
let's go hard pretzel six taking the dub
even though tampa's down three to zero
in the first period
with two total shots on net
zero i know the game is going about as
poorly as possible prince of wales
trophy
i'm not gonna touch it because you know
the blue jackets haven't got the job
done i heard tampa did touch it though
maybe comes back to bite him maybe a
little curse who knows looking cleaned
though
[Applause]
well you couldn't have asked for a much
worse outcome than what we just
witnessed seven to zero the final score
now the good news is the tampa fans are
still in good spirits we'll see what
they can do in game three now we know
tampa they're going to come back
stronger than ever you probably will get
this next up but that remains to be seen
best of luck
all right listen game one we were all in
for the abs game two we were all in for
tampa now we're rocking the two chains
we got the split shirt we're here at the
arena the lightning is in town storm's
coming down it's literally pouring
everyone's just sprinting inside it's a
mess out here
[Music]
you have to put this chain on for one
second no
no
what about like on your wrist
hold it in your hand just hold it
i don't want that
all right it's a bit of a long story but
as we came in we went back out we saw a
drum line we got absolutely poured on it
started storming so we got a new fit
we're here at the arena and the first
period just ended we thought it was
crazy in denver
these things it makes it so loud in this
arena cirelli had one of the nastiest
goals in the playoffs so far i don't
know if it was intentional we had the
goal called back it is madness here and
we are having some fun we're just
getting started
head middle one timer and he scores
looked like the puck went across the
line corey perry made sure
after 0 for 16 on the power play
they score a man up to go ahead six to
two i mean john not finished
we still got third period to go and then
taking it one game at a time we're
coming back
they're winning this game obviously they
went to the next one though uh yeah
we're at home we have to it's in tampa
it's electric in here going to seven
yeah going to seven you heard it here
first i appreciate it man the bolts are
back baby the fans are getting into this
we had the blowout there in denver in
game two it doesn't matter alright we
know never give up on tampa bay they're
back in this game back in this series
third period
[Music]
[Music]
we just took control of this series
[Music]
the elite minimum at the minimum
[Music]
[Music]
all right we just finished up here in
tampa the fans were absolutely wild
we're here and we're winning it i'm
telling you these are two very very
passionate fan bases going head to head
tons of love here in tampa could not
have asked for a better trip game one
two and three all absolutely electric so
i hope you guys enjoyed the ride i'm
nashville here with vr open ice and i'm
out
[Music]